foreign
Russia puts its military might on
display on Victory Day celebrating the
Soviet Union's victory over Nazi Germany
the choreographed spectacle is also a
chance for Moscow to Showcase his latest
weapons to potential foreign buyers with
Weaponry it's not just lucrative to
export it but it was it was also
important as a sort of geopolitical
Outreach for Russia
but the country's share of the global
weapons trade has been dropping since
2017 from 22 to 16 percent
and images of destroyed Russian weapons
across Ukraine have dented the
reputation of its arms industry so
here's why Russia's position as Well's
second largest weapons exporter is under
threat
[Music]
problems began in 2014 when Russia
annexed Crimea from Ukraine this led to
sanctions that limited the flow of
Western components that are crucial in
some Russian weapons
and last year's invasion of Ukraine
triggered more economic sanctions and
more complications for the Kremlin
not only has it become harder for
countries to buy Russian arms and
components is also more difficult to pay
for them now if you're paying in the
dollar for instance the US can sanction
you for doing that and so a good example
of that is the Philippines canceled an
order of Russian helicopters precisely
because of that
Russia's problems are creating
opportunities for competitors like
France
Serbia an ally of Moscow is in talks to
buy French rafale and fighter jets
another issue is Russia's own need for
weapons as is offensive in Ukraine drags
on
Russia has likely lost more than 2 000
tanks in Ukraine that's more than half
its operational Fleet according to one
estimate
this raises questions about how many
weapons Moscow has left for export
Russia's biggest arms by India said in
March that a major delivery from Moscow
wasn't going to take place because of
the Ukraine war China the next biggest
customer has also become less reliant on
russian-made weapons countries like
India and China are very important and
are likely harbinger of much worse to
come for the Russian arms industry
because they are starting to make more
of their own weaponry
some analysts say Russia's performance
on the battlefield could further weaken
demand for its equipment
some people would argue that it's not so
much Russian equipment that's bad it's
the tactics and the people who are using
it the ukrainians have used some Russian
armor for instance as tanks to great
effect but a lot of people would say
that it's very damaging for Russia
Russia didn't immediately respond to a
request for comments on the decline of
its Global arms exports
[Music]
these difficulties are likely to further
reduce moscow's share of the global
weapons trade
its arms exports dropped 31 in the five
years had ended in 2022 compared with
the same period ending in 2017. that's
according to a report by the Stockholm
International Peace Research Institute
the think tank uses multi-year periods
because yearly figures can be distorted
by large deliveries
it's very hard to say that therefore
Russia will continue to fade as a major
armed exporter but it's problematic on
so many different fronts for the Russian
time industry though there are obvious
reasons why if you were in the Russian
armed industry you would fear its future
foreign